do you have the initially that eater is
water
so I'm liking what I've been told I
better head to brothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to this video the
Rossi team challenge I was nominated by
brother talks have a pronounce his name
right who's a aid worker in Syria
working for one nation this is a this is
a challenge that's overdue actually
supposed to be done a long time ago but
due to being really busy but seeing the
reason it's hands on the videos that's
been the situation attacks has been
taking place in Syria obviously I
thought you know what you just need to
do this it's really important from here
with brother Mohammed some people are
doing it all right yeah well how are you
mate one gross I'm not doing too well
well I am okay well that's the thing you
know cause people in Syria and the
eating grass because of no future and
that's what point of the challenge and
you've got brass wood this classified
you yeah for that turn it looks like the
different flavors in there is it yeah in
a minute okay are you gonna eat all that
depends are you eat to eat in an equal
amount is there any justice in me eating
more than you are eating I'm gonna eat
this much why is this much only that
it's quite a lot you can't see it what
okay
is this more yes or is this equal for I
agree to eat all that if I eat all it is
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna let let me see
I'm not a little kid you know I don't
even my eating all of it I'm just gonna
try let me see what it tastes okay cuz
when brother took offense talks he tried
it I really got scared cuz he was
needing for me is it really that bad why
don't you try smella alright I really
try the same time here what are you
talking for that
when I see Egypt and I nominate you live
right here
I don't know me right now to do it right
good but it tastes like nothing you just
tease I feel like I'm eating people ha
ha ha inside he's suffering inside to be
a big man in it ha ha ha
it tastes like people who's gonna eat
people all right yeah um go go guys I'm
not a lead our in it my name is Mohammed
smelling in this how did that pigment
see in it you know because I use in my
culture we have these oh oh you some
wine he's a crazy man listen to say how
some of this okay all my brother that's
pure green that's all I can eat
and you like it relax with one little
wine
well that's how boots I said me eyes
have hot water we have this water like
that's just awkward Oh screw machina I
don't care you have the easier
oh yeah please raise mom okay
he will have some what's up
well guys we're gonna wait for him to it
swallow it you have any idea how big it
is well goodness gracious
something wrong yeah I'm just trying to
swallow it
you know when you wanna swallow it but
you but you can't cause it's just like
that you shouldn't eat it anyways I'm
gonna nominate you you finished it you
finished it who's out anyone people join
the one in my mouth
I take out duty this is so disgusting oh
no I'm gonna Nate Musa I'm gonna
nominate feasel yeah and I'm gonna
nominate and I'm gonna nominate and
we're nominate Almighty saw I nominate
these free to do the challenge can I add
one more person no no I need wrong not
going like this matter okay cuz I was
gonna nominate Shaquille
first of all okay my boy audience
started vlogging yeah yeah it's your
turn my friend okay second of all what
can Islam I want to travel the world
isn't it brother
how about you stick here first eat your
land are you I know we're not done we're
not done when I don't get hurt then this
it was my last one last well yeah yeah
my last bother yeah yeah Muslim blood we
go way back Bob five years ago a
bismillah eat it as well okay there you
go
Musa Faisal Oh Marissa most liberal
olive oil and I'm walking this lap they
go that's the challenge for you guys
make sure you send this to them and make
sure they do the challenge inshallah
yeah for now goodbye from us
let's go
shoot action
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo